je l'incarné la france représentait la
france et tout donner pour la france la
coupe du monde c'est autre chose c'est
le pays et le pays hier yann plus fort
représenter ton pays tu représentes tous
les gens de ton pays
je représente tous les français donc moi
j'ai jamais l'occasion encore de
discipline compétition comme ça et ça
doit être vraiment une émotion unique
c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire de
dire que le sort de tous les français le
bonheur de tous les français est entre
tes mains pour quel pays ça ferait pas
de bien de gagner une coupe du nom bien
sûr que ça ferait du bien que ce soit
sportivement même socialement ça enlève
plein de problèmes relève plein de
problèmes une coupe du monde s'est
regardé par des milliards de personnes
vous imaginez des milliards de personnes
talent pays qui est heureux tout le
monde est content que ce soit chez pas
moi le boulanger qui va travailler il
est content ici à la france malgré qu il
va faire ses baguettes avec beaucoup de
plaisir que ce soit la caissière que ce
soit la mère le président tout le monde
tout le monde va aller au travail avec
la banane tout le monde va bien dans ce
genre de compétition tu as beau avoir
les meilleurs joueurs c'est pas
forcément les meilleurs joueurs qui te
font gagner une compétition dans le
football vous savez vous avez pas
forcément besoin d'être copain j'ai
besoin de faire des sacrifices l'un pour
l'autre
j'ai besoin de bien vous entendre vous
n'avez pas forcément besoin de manger
chez le coach et le collègue tous les
soirs pour pour être un groupe soudé je
pense qu'on a
recoller les morceaux avec le public est
un travail qui a été fait sur l'image
même sur le terrain les joueurs est
exemplaire
le public essaye de remonter avec nous
en fait et ça c'est bien parce qu'on en
ce moment on a l'impression qu'on ne
fait qu'un en fait je peux plus être
monsieur tout le monde et je sais pas
moi tu es chez toi tu t'ennuies tu fais
une petite balade dehors tu vas prendre
une petite glace tu es monde
non non c'est fini ça j'aurais même pas
le temps de lécher la glace qu'il y aura
déjà 500 personnes thomas greiss rien de
garanti que si tu es bon tu vas réussir
parce qu'il faut plus que ça c'est
triste un c'est triste mais il faut plus
que ça il faut un mental à toute épreuve
déjà avant même d'être un bon joueur
oui c'est un jeu mais avant même de
savoir jouer à ce jeu là il faut un
mental à toute épreuve
parce que du jour au lendemain et ça
c'est pas des paroles en l'air ou du
bain
tout peut s'écrouler il faut être prêt
qu'il faut être prêt parce que on peut
vous monté tellement haut qu'on peut
vous redescendre aussi vite ce qui anime
un footballeur c'est ses rêves il voit
la poursuite de ses rêves
après une fois que j'aurai tous
remportés et j'espère la cambre de on me
demandera de courir je dirais c'est bon